hello YouTube chairs loss in your
friends this is grunge in here and
welcome to the second part of dirty
chess tricks to win fast in today's
lecture I am going to show you a very
good chess trick exist in the veresov
attack veresov attack recently get very
very popular thanks to the excellent
book published by Nigel Davis as well as
Andrew Martin has created one foxy
opening video for this and if you are
looking for the where also attack on the
YouTube the green castle block has done
some very good work on this nevertheless
today I am going to show you a one good
trick against the virus of attack white
start with the move d4 and here black
respond with the move Knight web sick
and here comes the first indication of
the virus Oh attack start with the move
Knight to c3 now Knight to c3 has a very
clear-cut idea that white wants to look
out for the movie for and if black
doesn't stop at this point then we get
some kind of transposition to either
park or the Zek perk or probably some
veered lines of the old Indian defense
so that's why it's very important at
this point black has to stop the movie
for and that's why defy fits the bill
so that's preventing the e4 and here
again as per the main theory of the Vera
so white plays Bishop to g5 so why does
very simple
yet again why it wants to capture that
black night that will give black a
double pawn and then white will quickly
go for the more a four so again black
has to stop this idea and there are a
few ways to play this position but the
best move here at this position is
Knight B to d7 so supporting the night
and now if white cannot manage to play
the e4 then this night is looking very
silly on c3 whatever the white will do
the whole move order should be geared up
to play the movie for normally there are
two ways white goes for this and which I
have highlighted by the arrows over here
so one way is to play f3 and the second
way is to play immediate Queen d3 and
then look out for the move a for now if
you open place f3 which you will not
often see in your game then you can do
similar which I have done in this video
but here I am going to concentrate more
on the move Queen to d3 and that will be
the case 70 to 80 percent of the time
the simple reason is it back in the
square to King castle on the Queen side
and not only that it's also supporting
the movie 4 and it looks very very
aggressive at the first point and that's
why it's a choice of many players
however this can be easily diffused by
following more order so first of all
black will play the move at 6 attacking
the bishop so if again white will take
the 9 then black will gain a bishop pair
for nothing so the very logical reply by
the white will be Bishop goes to the
ashfall and now you play a very
wonderful move which is the move
c6
and it completely stopped the movie for
now you may be asking how it doesn't
look like a move right it's just this
point is just protecting this defy pawn
and apart from that it doesn't have
anything but if you believe it or not it
will stop
efore and if your opponent foolishly
play efore that's where our dark each
estwick exists and I will give you
guarantee that many many people are
playing this so let's see what happens
if white plays the movie for now after E
for black should certainly capture this
pawn with the knight and again if Y does
not recapture then white will a pawn
down for nothing so obviously white will
go for this sequence so white will
capture this Knight and after black
recaptured white will capture upon and
it looks like white is all good right
it's just castling on the queenside in a
minute and then all this species will
come out and white will have a fantastic
game but can you below white is lost at
this point
let me show you how so first black will
give the screen check now whether the
King has mu or the only reply left to
block the check which is c3 which will
most of the time will be played by your
opponent
then you play the moon GFI attacking the
bishop so bishop has the only square
left which is Bishop to g3 and now comes
the whole idea which is you play the
move
fi and now you can see not only it's
attacking the Queen right now but if the
Queen moves which I think your opponent
has - then this pawn will go further and
it will trap this bishop and this is a
very wonderful trick exist in the Vera
so there are two option for white white
can move the Queen so for example let's
say Queen goes to the f3 and then black
and push this pawn and gain a valuable
piece and if your opponent is attacking
player he might go for this counter
which is the move B for counter
attacking you're clean but after a very
simple Queen to a3 White has to deal
with another trick which is now black is
threatening to capture the c3 that will
have the rook in the corner
so again white has to defend that threat
and let's say whichever plays the Queen
will go let's say Queen goes to f3 then
again we'll trap this Bishop so this is
a wonderful chess trick exist in varus
of attack and especially if you have any
opponent playing this opening frequently
then you might want to try out even if
let's say your opponent doesn't fall for
this chess trick you will have a nice
opening and that means you will
permanently stop White's efore that
means you are coming out from all
opening difficulties so I hope you enjoy
this wonderful chess trick please feel
free to comment on my video and I will
meet you soon bye